cette vidéo est destinée très
spécifiquement comme son titre l indique
aux élèves de prépa hec et étant donné
que j'échange beaucoup depuis plusieurs
années avec les élèves de prépa je sais
de toute la france et que dans nos
échanges
je le tutoie et bien je vais passer au
tutoiement dans cette vidéo je m'adresse
donc à toi cher préparationnaires je me
présente parce que tu ne me connais
peut-être pas je suis romain le créateur
du site
mais l'idée de culture générale et
auteur du manuel éponyme
je connais très bien la prépa hec parce
que je suis moi même passé par là parce
que je donne des cours de culture
générale à des élèves de prépa hec
depuis une dizaine d'années et enfin
parce que j'ai édité plusieurs manuels
un destination des élèves de prépa hec
dernière petite précision me concernant
je travaille toujours en tandem avec
aristote que pau 6 essais aristote avec
un h
parce qu'il est né en 2011 allez trêve
de précision dans cette vidéo je vais
commenter dans le détail une
dissertation culture générale qui a été
notée 17 sur 20 pour concours d'entrée
de hec de 2017
tu peux télécharger la copie de concours
avec ma correction une dissertation
entièrement rédigé sur le même sujet
soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit sur celui qui est dans la
description après tu as juste à
m'indiquer la filière et ton adresse
email pour recevoir la copie alors cette
copie de concours ce n'est pas n'importe
laquelle
c'est celle de fanny étudiante en
deuxième année à chausser à l'heure où
je tourne cette vidéo c'est fanny qui
m'a contactée par facebook il ya un peu
plus d'un an pour me dire qu'elle avait
réussi l'épreuve de dissertation de
culture générale grâce à ma méthode dite
des paragraphes celle de mes petits
manuels 50 paragraphe tout cuit alors
fanny n'en avait qu'un elle
de manuel mais désormais il y à le faire
c'est la version références classiques
et puis le rouge
la version références originales donc
fanni a réussi l'épreuve avec 17 sur 20
or comme elle le dit dans son témoignage
pour elle ça n'était pas une mince
affaire la dissertation de culture
générale elle avoue clairement son but
c'était seulement d'éviter le pire en
philo elle m'a plus précisément écrit je
n'ai jamais été très bon en philo je
n'aimais pas travailler cette matière en
prépa alors que je voulais seulement au
début évité le pire en philo j'ai
finalement eu de bonnes notes 14 les
millions et 1 sec 17 h c'est
essentiellement grâce à la méthode des
paragraphes plus la méthode des
paragraphes tout cuit c'est donc celle
manuel 50 par ailleurs depuis
est ce qu'il y a de très intéressant
dans la copie de concours de fanny c'est
qu'elle a d'un côté appliqué très
rigoureusement même eto'o des
paragraphes
mais de l'autre elle s'est servi des
paragraphes précis du manuel avec
beaucoup de liberté
en fait si je généralise ya grosso modo
trois catégories d'élèves
ce tout d'abord qu'ils apprennent les
paragraphes du manuel
parker et les recrache le jour j qui
peut donner de bons résultats mais ce
n'est vraiment pas ce que je recommande
deuxième catégorie ensuite il ya les
élèves qui apprennent les paragraphes du
manuel
mais qui font un vrai effort le jour j
pour adapter chaque paragraphe au sujet
c'est de mon point de vue la meilleure
manière de faire celle aussi qui
conviendra au plus grand nombre d'élèves
de prépa hec
enfin troisième catégorie certains
élèves comme fanny attachent plus
d'importance au format précis des
paragraphes du manuel et à la manière de
les utiliser
c'est à dire à la méthode des
paragraphes ils connaissent les
paragraphes mais pas par coeur et il les
utilise très librement tout en
appliquant très rigoureusement la
méthode des paragraphes
donc si tu as peur d'avoir les même
paragraphe que d'autres candidats le
jour j ce qui est évidemment soit dit en
passant
un fantasme paranoïaque parce qu'il ya
trop de paragraphe est que trop peu
d'élèves utilisent
les manuels et méthodes des paragraphes
bref si tu n'arrives pas à te
débarrasser de cette peur infondée et
bien tu peux utiliser les paragraphes du
manuel et la méthode des paragraphes
comme l'a fait fun mais je vais
t'expliquer plus en détail ce que ça
veut dire dans la suite de la vidéo en
commentant la copie je te rappelle que
tu peux la télécharger soit en cliquant
sur le lien qui apparaît en haut à
droite de la vidéo soit sur celui qui
est dans la description
je vais concentrer mon commentaire sur
quatre points tout d'abord l'efficacité
globale de la méthodologie de fanny
ensuite l'efficacité de son usage de ma
méthode des paragraphes l'efficacité
également de son expression écrite et
puis je soulignerai bien sûr les erreurs
qui auraient pu lui coûter des points
je comparerais aussi à certains moments
la copie de famille avec ma propre
correction en revanche je ne parlerai
pas du foot c'est à dire du thème de
l'année 2017 qui était la parole parce
que c'est sans intérêt pour toi en
termes de méthode
enfin je vais essayer de me mettre à la
place du correcteur de découvrir et de
lire la copie comme lui même si moi je
te préviens je vais prendre davantage de
temps à l'est plus dans le détail puis
je crois aussi que je suis plus
exigeants voici le sommaire de la vidéo
je vais d'abord analyser la première
impression générale que produit la copie
et puis je vais commenter ces partis
dans l'ordre suivant introduction
conclusion grand un grand 2 et enfin
qu'en 3 je conclurai chacune de ces
parties de mon commentaire
avec une synthèse des principaux points
positifs ce dont tu veux at inspiré et
des principaux points négatifs
ce que tu dois éviter et puis bien sûr
je ferai une conclusion finale dans
laquelle je te dirai si fanny méritait
vraiment 17
si jamais tu veux aller directement à
une partie précise de la vidéo tu as
juste à regarder dans le minutage de la
vidéo qui est disponible dans la
description
enfin tu peux me poser toutes les
questions dans les commentaires et je
m'engage à répondre à chacune d'entre
elles allaient maintenant il faut mettre
les mains dans le cambouis je te précise
que le thème de culture générale de 2017
était la parole et que le sujet tout
mais hec était faire parler un texte
ouais il était plutôt difficile voire
très difficile mais fanni qui avait
seulement pour ambition d'éviter le pire
en philo s'en est très bien sorti grâce
à ma méthode des parallèles voyons voir
la première impression générale que
produit sa copie allez une petite
récompense pour donner du courage
aristote parce qu'il ya du travail et
c'est parti
voici donc la dissertation de concours
que tu as plus téléchargées le
correcteur commence généralement par
jauger en quelques secondes
l'état général de la copie ah mais ça me
fait penser il faut que je te parle d'un
truc est ce que tu sais ce que c'est le
biais de confirmation
c'est un effet psychologique qui se
produit dans de nombreux domaines et qui
est très puissant
par exemple si tu rencontres une
nouvelle personne tu en as d'une
première impression dès les premières
secondes tu remarques consciemment ou
inconsciemment plein de choses qui sont
connotés positivement ou négativement à
tes yeux
et bien cette première impression est
fugace mais d'une importance cruciale
car elle crée un billet si cette
nouvelle personne produit sur toi une
bonne toutes premières impressions
tu vas avoir tendance à vouloir
systématiquement confirmer cette
première impression en interprétant
positivement ce qu'elle dit est fait par
la suite
et inversement si la toute première
impression est mauvaise du beau jeu à
venir comme le correcteur est un être
humain une dissertation produit elle
aussi un biais de confirmation
une copie qui fournit les signes de la
conformité aux attentes du correcteur
l'entraînera a priori inconsciemment à
voir confirmer cette première impression
favorable c'est-à-dire sur noter la
dissertation
inversement une copie d'un abord
désagréable à risque d'être sous noté tu
as donc tout intérêt à faire en sorte
que tu as dissertation produisent une
bonne première impression sur le
correcteur on va voir plus précisément
comment faire en regardant la copie de
fanni c'est parti pour de bon un stop
alors quelle première impression la
dissertation de fanny fournit-elle bon
au niveau de la calligraphie ça va elle
est plutôt lisible pour une copie de
concours lui trop petit ni trop grosse
on remarque immédiatement dès
l'introduction les alinéas bien marquer
ce qui facilite évidemment la lecture
c'est donc un premier bon point comme le
lecteur lit des centaines de copies dans
un court laps de temps
tout ce qui lui rend la tâche
moins pénible est susceptible
d'accroître sa tolérance ensuite les
références sont bien souligné mais bon
ça tous les candidats le fond il n'y a
en général pas de problème je descends à
la page 2 on voit que les grande partie
introduction grant un grand deux grands
3 et conclusions sont bien espacées et
que fanni a même pris l'initiative de
sauter une ligne entre ces paragraphes
c'est un choix judicieux parce que ces
paragraphes sont assez longs alors comme
moi je suis assez tatillon je remarque à
la page 3 que fanny utilisent des
guillemets anglais au lieu de guillemets
français n'est pas très grave mais c'est
à évident tu te souviendras ça ce sont
des guillemets français ce que tu dois
utiliser en dissertation culture
générale et ceux ci ce sont des
guillemets anglais a réservé pour
l'anglais qui est à élever un ou l v2 si
je ne m'abuse
[Musique]
je continue de descendre
je remarque une conclusion partielle à
la fin de chaque grande partie ce qui
est une caractéristique supplémentaire
d'une copie sérieuse
je remarque aussi comme c'est le cas
dans la plupart des bonnes copies que
les paragraphes se font un peu moins
longs au fur et à mesure qu'on avance
mais bon en regardant rapidement leur
taille me semble toutefois rester dans
une proportion tolérable par rapport à
celle des premiers de la dissertation
je continue encore de descendre et on
arrive à la conclusion je suis
agréablement surpris par sa longueur qui
me donne l'impression favorable à d'un
travail achevé
fanni ne s'est pas contenté de 3,4
league je check le nombre de pages 10
pages c'est peut-être un tout petit peu
au dessus de la moyenne sans être
excessif ça aussi c'est plutôt un bon
signe alors que conclure de cette
première impression
honnêtement il n'y a pas photo la
dissertation de fanny produit une
première impression positive voire très
positive du coup biais de confirmation
oblige sa note a de bonnes chances
d'être tiré vers le haut voici plus
précisément les trois atouts de la copie
de fanny dont tu peux inspirer pour
produire une bonne première impression
je te donne les atouts par ordre
d'importance décroissante atout numéro 1
le marquage des alinéas atout numéro 2
l'aération de la copie atout numéro 3 le
relatif équilibre des grandes parties
jeudi relative parce qu'il n'est pas
parfait comme la dissertation de fanny
possède trois atouts on est enclin à
penser dès les premières secondes de
correction qu'il s'agit d'une bonne
voire d'une très bonne copie et encore
une fois ça crée un biais de
confirmation positif en vertu duquel le
correcteur aura tendance à remarquer en
priorité les choses réussies dans la
suite de la copie allez je passe
maintenant comme le correcteur à la
lecture détaillée de l'ain
production je rappelle que tu peux me
poser toutes tes questions dans les
commentaires
allez c'est parti pour l'intro
[Musique]
alors je regarde un peu la tête de
l'introduction et mais ça ressemble
beaucoup à ma méthodologie sa petite
précision supplémentaire
en fait comme fannie avaient travaillé
avec certaines de mes dissertations
parce que chaque année j'en donne
gratuitement plusieurs aux élèves
inscrits à la newsletter
donc comme fanny les avais lu elle a
appliqué ma méthodologie de
l'introduction un paragraphe parents jeu
marqué par un alinéa
c'est particulièrement pratique à lire
et à corriger ce que je vais faire c'est
commenter l'instruction de fanny
paragraphe par paragraphe comme ça je
vais aussi te donner des conseils de
méthodologie pour l'introduction de la
dissertation
allez on retourne dans la copie comme
dans la méthodologie le premier
paragraphe est intelligemment consacré à
la croche et uniquement à la croche
fanny évoque un documentaire de 2016 à
voix haute qui raconte la préparation
d'un concours d'éloquence par deux
jeunes étudiantes quartier donc là il
s'agit bien sûr d'une référence
originale pour rappel comme les
étudiants de prépa je sais me pose
souvent la question
il existe selon moi 5 type d'accrochage
possible je te les donne pas un ordre de
difficulté et de risques croissants
tu peux commencer ta copie par une
référence par exemple des cars avance
dans le discours de la méthode que tu
peux utiliser plus précisément une
citation par exemple quand tu prends
confiance en la confiance tu deviens
confiant un truisme de jean claude van
damme
tu peux raconter une anecdote par
exemple les disciples des piqûres se
réunissaient dans l'école dite du jardin
ou et c'est un plus difficile tu peux
faire référence à un fait d'actualité ou
un fait récent par exemple une équipe de
chercheurs du laboratoire de
neurobiologie de l'université américaine
de stanford a montré en septembre 2018
que ces terrains
et enfin tu peux partir d'une
statistique par exemple selon une étude
de 2010 est du cabinet deloitte
un français sur neuf et est abonnée à
une salle de fitness en 2016 fanny elle
comme tu le vois elle a opté pour la
première solution est sa référence est
original à deux titres
il s'agit d'un documentaire et ce
documentaire est récent alors ça pouvait
être risqué mais le risque est largement
couvert par la pertinence de la croche
sur le fond et puis aussi par le soin
apporté à le démontrer sur la forme
de manière générale une référence
récente demande un effort supplémentaire
sur le plan de l'expression écrite parce
que la rigueur et le classicisme du
style contribuer tafer tolérer
l'originalité entre guillemets de la
référence une référence récente
introduite avec des défauts de style
produirait une dangereuse impression de
vulgarité c'est ça la vasque fanny elle
a coché toutes les cases pour que le
correcteur adhère à son choix son
paragraphe dac roche développent un peu
la référence dans les deux premières
phrases il justifie la pertinence de la
référence par rapport aux sujets c'est
la fonction de troisième phrase
et puis enfin le paragraphe d'across et
rédigé très efficacement
il est très clair et ne comporte aucune
faute d'expression
en dernière instance ma seule réticence
et que la dernière phrase de la croche
que j'appelle dans la méthodologie la
justification du sujet ma réticence et
que cette phrase soit une question parce
que ça peut entraîner une confusion
entre l'enjeu de la croche d'une part
qui simplement de faire rentrer le
correcteur dans la dissertation en
créant un biais de confirmation positif
ma réticence et que ça crée une
confusion entre cet enjeu est l'enjeu de
la problématisation d'autres pas il ne
faut donc pas confondre les enjeux de la
croche et de la problématisation comme
l'a un peu fait famille en effet plus
les enjeux de l'introduction sont
clairement et précisément délimité plus
la lecture du correcteur sera facile ou
moins pénibles mois pour conclure le
paragraphe d'akreuch de fanni j'aurais
plutôt écrit quelque chose comme cet
exemple nous invite à réfléchir plus
profondément à l'influencent de la
parole orale sur la parole écrite
allez je passe maintenant au deuxième
paragraphe de l'introduction bon fanny
reste fidèle à ma méthodologie de
l'introduction
elle consacre ce deuxième paragraphe à
la définition des termes du sujet je
constate aussi qu'elle s'inspire du
format de mai paragraphe tout cuit en
commençant avec une phrase aussi clair
que courte avec un seul verbe conjugué
notamment l'expression faire parler un
texte revêt différentes significations
avec cette phrase elle indique aux
correcteurs de manière très transparente
qu'elle s'apprêtait à énoncer les
divergences possible de l'expression
aucune prise de tête
fanny c'est exactement ce qu'elle fait
et le correcteur le sait lui aussi tout
est très clair et ça énormément des
élèves de prépa hec me le dise le style
très claire des paragraphes du manuel
les a fait beaucoup progresser en
expression écrite en pratique beaucoup
reprennent exactement le même format de
paragraphes non seulement en
dissertation de culture générale mais
aussi en histoire ou en économie en
contraction et en synthèse en langues
c'est ce que j'explique dans la préface
du manuel 50 paragraphe tout cuit ce
manuel ne sert pas seulement à être plus
efficaces dans le développement de la
dissertation en le préparant la vence il
donne plus généralement une véritable
méthode une méthode à la portée de tout
élève de prépa hec pour écrire
clairement et puis ceux dont les
candidats ne se rendent généralement pas
encore compte c'est qui écrire
clairement c'est une compétence profonde
qui sera ensuite cruciale au cours de
leur vie professionnelle
bref j'ai un peu digresser là mais ce
que je veux te dire c'est que ma méthode
des paragraphes sert aussi à écrire plus
clairement
je reviens la définition des termes dans
la copie de feng après la première
phrase
elle précise ensuite sur le fond que les
divers sens de l'expression sont
déterminées par le rôle de l'acteur
celui qui fait parler ou par l'effet
produit par la parole donné vie aux
textes le rendre parle alors sur la
forme ce paragraphe de définition des
termes est très efficace
l'expression est très clair on distingue
facilement les idées et les phrases
s'enchaînent avec fluidité grâce aux
liens logiques présent dans chacune
d'elles tu vois en effet il y à aussi
tantôt tantôt pas seulement également
bon il y en a tellement que ça devient
chiant
et encore aussi ainsi et alors bref on
est servi fanni ne lésine pas de ce côté
là donc sur la forme elle a su sur le
plan du fond et de la méthode aura en
revanche c'est moins bien ce que fait
fanny dans ce paragraphe
c'est tout d'abord définir l'expression
complète alors qu'il faut la découpe et
puis elle confond l'enjeu de la
définition des termes avec celui de la
problématisation or il suffisait en gros
de définir l'expression faire parler et
puis le nom comme un texte
voici la définition des termes que j'ai
proposé dans ma correction je te la
montre quelques secondes et je te laisse
mettre la vidéo pose si tu veux la lire
en dérive entre rapidement elle vers une
problématisation complexe famille finit
par commettre une déficience logique
ainsi cela revient à jouer sur les sons
et le sens des bombes non faire en sorte
qu'un texte devienne parlant pour le
lecteur ou l'auditeur ça ne revient pas
à jouer sur les sons et le sens des mots
mais bon je ne suis pas censé parler du
fond et le correcteur n'a pas le temps
ou l'envié de remarquer ce type d'erreur
tu peux juste retenir que dévier de la
méthodologie t'entraîneras à commettre
des erreurs sur le feu
fanny pose ensuite différentes questions
alors elles sont introduites et formuler
clairement naise elles paraissent quand
même parachute et donc sur le fond la
définition des termes de fanni n'est pas
terrible après le sujet était vraiment
difficile
allez je passe au paragraphe suivant
dédié normalement à la problématisation
je crois qu'un petit rappel de
méthodologie s'impose qu'est ce que la
problématisation c'est la partie de
l'introduction de talent dissertation
qui consiste à diviser le problème de
l'énoncé en dessous problème la
problématique c'est la question qui est
donc le problème général posé par le
sujet et auquel tu doit proposer des
éléments de réponse dans ta de
dissertation en pratique je te conseille
d'entamer le paragraphe de
l'introduction consacré à la
problématisation 3e paragraphe parce que
jeune homme dans ma méthodologie de la
dissertation le point de départ de la
réflexion
alors qu'est ce que le point de départ
de la réflexion
c'est l'aspect le plus évidemment
frappant du sujet cet aspect doit être
une idée à la fois évidente est simple
pour le sujet de cette dissertation
faire parler un texte par exemple le
meilleur point de départ de la réflexion
était de mon point de vue la parente
impossibilité de conférer à un texte la
faculté de la parole orale
c'est à dire que la correspondance entre
la métaphore de l'énoncé faire parler un
texte d'une part et la réalité et ces
phénomènes
d'autre part cette correspondance
semblent de prime abord problématiques
voire impossibles
dit plus simplement au sens propre faire
parler un texte
c'est une hypothèse délirante cette idée
évidente est simple prise pour point de
départ ou tremplin de la réflexion j'ai
pris l'habitude dans mes dissertations
de la développer en quelques phrases
minimum 2 au début du 3e paragraphe de
l'introduction de la dissertation
voici ce que ça donne dans ma correction
comme il ya une minute mais la vidéo en
pause si tu veux lire le passage
à
[Musique]
alors ce passage est exceptionnellement
longtemps - d'introduction mais c'est
parce que j'ai voulu clarifier le
problème au maximum en raison de la
difficulté du sujet les différentes
questions de la problématisation
idéalement 3 qui exprimé sous problème
du problème principal ces questions ne
viennent que dans un second temps
puisqu'elle découle du point de départ
de la réflexion
bon j'espère que c'est un peu plus clair
pour toi avec ce petit point méthodo sur
le paragraphe consacré à la
problématisation dans l'introduction de
la dissertation je retourne à la copie
de fanny fanny elle consacre ce
troisième paragraphe de son introduction
à une problématique trop longue et trop
compliqué d'ailleurs c'est peut-être le
plus gros défaut de sa copie en quoi la
capacité à faire parler un texte si elle
revêt certes des aspects positifs
implique-t-elle des dangers créant
notamment un rapport fiduciaire c'est à
dire un rapport fondé sur la confiance
entre les hommes et entre les types de
parole en nettement ses prises de tête
bon fanny a néanmoins réussi à faire
passer la pilule
grâce à l'efficacité de son style et
puis aussi plus précisément grâce à
l'illusion de cohérence produite par les
liens logiques par exemple la phrase de
ce paragraphe commence par là d'herbe
dès lors alors même qu'elle ne constitue
pas une conséquence de ce qui précède
donc là l escroc qu'un peu le correcteur
allez je passe au dernier paragraphe de
son introduction
l'annnonce de plans dans mes
dissertations je saute généralement une
ligne entre la problématique et annonces
de plans mais c'est un détail qui
n'influence en rien le correcteur temps
que les choses sont claires pour lui de
même les variantes de formulation de
l'annnonce de plans ou encore la
question de savoir s'il faut préciser le
numéro de la partie entre parenthèses ça
ce sont des choses avec lesquelles tu ne
dois pas te prendre la tête
ce sont des broutilles qui ne méritent
pas à ton attention
souviens toi qu'on donne souvent son
attention à l'accessoire au détriment de
l'essentiel
alors le plan de famille dans un premier
temps voyons qu'il existe différentes
manières de faire parler un texte de le
rendre vivant
expliquons alors les raisons pour
lesquelles un écrivain un orateur ou un
auditeur souhaite faire parler un texte
montre ont finalement que cette capacité
à faire parler un texte avait des
limites provoquant des dangers pour les
hommes et pour la parole elle même c'est
très clair mais elle aurait pu éviter la
répétition de l'expression du sujet
faire parler un texte ou alors ne l'a
répété que dans la troisième phrase dans
cette troisième phrase d'ailleurs
provoqué des dangers n'est pas très
élégant
je préfère par exemple créer des risques
mais c'est un détail non le gros défaut
de son plan c'est qu'ils ne répondent
pas à rigoureusement à la question de la
problématique qui porte si je la
simplifie sur les potentiels dangers
liés à la capacité de faire parler un
texte pourtant le principe de
méthodologie à appliquer et simple la
problématique exprime sous la forme
question le problème général du sujet et
le plan du développement de la
dissertation constitue une réponse
dialectique et progressive en plusieurs
parties à cette question
dans ma méthodologie la qualité du plan
se vérifie en effectuant ce que
j'appelle un test de pertinence tu lis
simplement à la suite la problématique
est l' annonce de plan pour savoir dans
quelle mesure le plan constitue bien une
réponse pertinente à la problématique si
tu touches la cible c'est que ton plan
est bon dans le plan de fanny legrand
teint et le grand 2 sont à l'évidence
hors sujet par rapport à la question en
quoi la capacité à faire parler un texte
implique t elle des engins en fait c'est
quasi uniquement son grand troyes qui
répond à sa problématique
faisons maintenant le test avec la
problématique et le plan de ma
correction lusage d'un texte pourrait
t'il vraiment recourir à une forme de
parole orale issus de la parole écrite
elle même si la parole au sens strict
semblent de prime abord impropre à
décrire l'usagé d'un texte il apparaît
cependant qu'elle possède un rôle
fondateur à l'égard de la parole écrite
c'est pourquoi elle rend tout de même
possible d usage de la parole écrite qui
révèle une forme de réalité au sein même
du texte
tu vois là ça colle je pense que le plan
aspects qu aux limites de fanny passe
tout de même parce qu'il est malgré tout
très clair l'efficacité de la forme
qu'on pense les déficiences de feu alors
petite conclusion sur l'introduction de
fait tu l'as compris est loin d'être
parfaite
voici les trois points positifs que tu
peux en retenir
je te les présentes par ordre
d'importance décroissante premier point
son style est d'une clarté idéal pour
les concours deuxième point la division
en quatre paragraphes comme dans mes
dissertations facilite la lecture du
correcteur et troisième point la croche
réussi créer un biais de confirmation
positif maintenant il ya aussi des
défauts que tu ne dois pas reproduire je
te les présente toujours par ordre
d'importance décroissante
tout d'abord le mélange des enjeux en
l'occurrence la définition des termes et
la problématisation ce qu'il faut je te
lis déjà dit c'est que tu consacres un
seul et unique enjeu achats
paragraphe de l'introduction accroche
définition des termes problématisation
et annonces de plans deuxième défaut de
l'intro de fanny la complexité de la
problématique troisième défaut principal
la déconnexion de la problématique et du
plan on a fait le test de pertinence n'a
lui la problématique et le plan à la
suite et ça ne marche pas donc encore
une fois l'introduction de fanni est
loin d'être parfaite pour autant
l'impression globale qui en émane est
positive voire très positive selon les
copies corrigées juste avant ça pour
deux raisons la première c'est que le
sujet était difficile et la seconde
raison c'est que comme je le dis souvent
la clarté de l'expression écrite est
survalorisé au concours du coup si je me
mets à la place du correcteur je trouve
qu'à ce stade la copie de fanni est bien
parti pour être notée entre 14 et 20 la
pression globale que j'en ai et pour
l'instant positive voire très positive
je vais maintenant commenté la
conclusion elle est souvent lui en
tandem avec l'introduction parce que ça
permet d'évaluer la cohérence globale de
la dissertation
si tu as des questions je te rappelle
que ça se passe dans les commentaires
alors je te rappelle que la finalité
conventionnelle de la conclusion c'est
simplement de boucler la boucle
rappelant les résultats de la réflexion
cette partie n'est donc pas un enjeu de
fond mais uniquement de forme de mon
point de vue la manière la plus simple
de s'y prendre et de rédiger une sorte
de mini contraction du développement
dans mes conclusions
je résume généralement chaque grande
partie du développement
en deux phrases la première pour évoquer
l'idée générale et la seconde pour
synthétiser les trois arguments
maintenant qu'en est il de la conclusion
de fanny sa conclusion n'est pas bâcler
comme c'est le cas dans de nombreuses
copies et elle présente les qualités
attendues elles synthétisent le propos
du développement avec la même efficacité
de style que celle de l'introduction
et puis elle ne cherche pas à faire
lever le correcteur de sa chaise avec
des réflexions ou transcendante
tu peut remarquer que même dans cette
toute dernière partie d'une importance
marginale sur le fond alors même qu'elle
est probablement pressé par le temps
fanny apporte un soin particulier à la
cohérence du paragraphe en liant
systématiquement toutes les phrases
entre elles les phrases 2 3 et 4
développe et précise l'idée générale de
la toute première c'est encore une fois
le format de mai paragraphe tout cuit
puis l'on trouve dans les phrases 5 6 et
7 des liens respectivement d'opposition
néanmoins d'admission plus encore et de
conséquence donc de manière générale
contrairement à ce que croient beaucoup
d'élèves en prépa hec
si ce soin particulier qui fait sortir
la copie du lot et non pas une référence
original que le correcteur ne remarquera
probablement même pas ou bien qui ne
sera pas original pour lui qui lit d'une
teigne au petit déjeuner pour conclure
comme l'écrit fanny les trois atouts de
sa conclusion dont tu peux inspirer ce
son numéro 1 sa consistance
parce qu'elle ne se réduit pas trop
ligne numéro 2 la clarté de l'expression
est numéro trois
l'efficacité de la synthèse du
développement
en clair je trouve que la conclusion de
famille est quasiment parfaite
son seul défaut c'est d'être un peu
moins rigoureusement scolaire et ça être
rigoureusement scolaire c'est une
qualité dans la perspective des concours
donc je la trouve un peu moins scolaire
à la fin du paragraphe en particulier
parce qu'elle termine avec une image
journalistique un jeu à double tranchant
qui est inadaptée mais bon ce détail mis
à part fanny a rédigé une très bonne
conclusion
allez je passe au développement de la
dissertation
comme tu sais probablement déjà le
correcteur le lit plus rapidement
souvent en diagonale ça n'est donc pas
ce qu'il ya de plus important dans la
copie c'est l'introduction qui sert un
peu d'échantillons représentatifs de
toute la dissertation qui est la partie
la plus importante
mais bon le développement n'est pas à
négliger pour autant aller on retourne
dans la copie de fanny alors la première
chose que je remarque est que fanni n'a
pas fait l'introduction partielle pour
son grand teint par introduction
partielle
j'entends deux trois phrases qui
rappelle l'idée générale de la grande
partie voici par exemple celle de ma
correction la pertinence de l'expression
faire part à lire un texte apparaît de
prime abord problématique dans la mesure
où elles négligent la parente
hétérogénéité de la parole orale et de
la parole écrite
or cette hétérogénéité semble
insurmontable pour plusieurs raisons que
fanni sont soit passé n'est pas grave du
tout
li bonnes ou très bonnes copies sont
plein d'imperfections
quand les mauvaises sont pleines de
détails réussi je regarde le premier
paragraphe du grand temps il ne s'agit
pas d'un paragraphe du manuel 50
paragraphe tout cuit je te le dis tout
de suite c'est en fait un paragraphe
préparé par fanny elle même sur le
modèle de ceux du manuel comme je le
recommande dans ma méthode des
paragraphes la première phrase est
extrêmement clair même si elle aurait pu
être plus courte en mettant le point
après le mot forme
la locution adverbiale tout d'abord un
type bien aux correcteurs qu'elle va
présenter ses idées de manière ordonnée
la suite du paragraphe est aussi limpide
très bien structuré tout d'abord
premièrement également et les liens
logiques produit c'est une bonne
impression de cohérence
la référence m introduite qu'à la 4e
phrase ce qui montre que famille a
compris que la dissertation est un
exercice d'argumentation et que dans cet
exercice les références ne servent qu'à
donner plus de force aux arguments
[Musique]
l'expression faire parler un texte
revient à quatre reprises ce qui
témoigne de l'obsession kerfany de
traiter très précisément le sujet et
uniquement le sujet le seul défaut du
paragraphe et la présence de deux
références verlaine et francis ponge qui
sont des références classiques
à quoi s'ajoute le fait que la seconde
est évoquée en une seule phrase de mon
point de vue deux références dans un
même paragraphe
c'est vraiment un mauvais choix beaucoup
d'élèves me disent qu'ils le font pour
donner davantage de références aux
correcteurs mais je te le redis les
références ne sont pas ce qu'il ya de
plus important en dissertation et puis
surtout les supposés avantages d'un
couple de référence ne compense pas les
inconvénients il y en a trois principaux
déjà c'est un facteur de complexité
c'est assez difficile comme ça de
mobiliser une seule référence
et puis il peut être très difficile de
relier les deux références
deuxième inconvénient principal de
référence dans le même paragraphe ça
risque de produire de la confusion chez
correcteurs alors que je te le redis tu
ton but c'est de lui rendre la vie plus
facile
enfin troisième et dernière
inconvénients ça peut être pris pour du
nem japon et d'ailleurs tu verras qu'il
y en a dans la copie de famille en
conclusion je te recommande donc de
concentrer chaque paragraphe sur une
seule et unique référence qui soit la
plus pertinente possible par rapport à
l'argument la famille un peu dévié de ma
méthode des paragraphes mais au global
le premier paragraphe de son
développement est très efficace
je passe au paragraphe suivant
ce deuxième paragraphe est très
similaire au premier c'est encore un
paragraphe que fanny à préparer elle
même en s'inspirant de ceux de mou
manuel puis adapté au sujet alors il est
introduit très simplement par l'adverbe
ensuite qui a tout de même le mérite de
présenter explicitement en ordre il
commence lui aussi par une phrase très
clair et cette fois-ci courte qui expose
l'argument ensuite l'orateur quand il
déclame un texte peut également le faire
parler
c'est à dire lui donner vie le
paragraphe est bien structuré et d'une
lecture fluide grâce aux biens logique
ensuite pour ce faire deux fois alors en
effet bon j'arrête parce que ça ne
finira jamais grosso modo il ya un lien
logique par phrase la référence n'est
présenté qu'à la 4e phrase l'expression
faire parler un texte revient cette fois
cette fois là elle n'y va pas avec le
dos de la cuillère famille et enfin la
conclusion partielle rappelle l'argument
en le précisant
[Musique]
alors on retrouve le même défaut que
dans le premier paragraphe de référence
ils sont également classique
sinon c'est paragraphe est lui aussi
globalement très efficace je passe au 3e
paragraphe toujours préparé par fanny
elle-même selon ma méthode
ce dernier paragraphe est cependant
sensiblement plus court que les deux
précédents je dirais qu'il est plus
court d'environ 40% après il est quasi
similaire sur la forme
conformément thomas méthode des
paragraphes une première phrase très
clair présente l'argument enfin
l'auditeur ou le lecteur a également la
capacité à faire parler un texte
c'est-à-dire à donner différentes
interprétations au texte
le paragraphe a toujours une structure
explicite moule de liens logiques
l'introduction de la référence est faite
à la 4è phrase l'expression de l'énoncé
faire parler un texte apparaît trois
fois et enfin on retrouve bien une mini
conclusions partielles ici le spectateur
est libre de faire parler le texte comme
il l'entend
ce troisième et dernier paragraphe se
distingue des deux premiers à deux
titres
il comporte une seule et unique
référence et en cela je le trouve plus
efficace même si les moins développés et
puis la référence un film de 2016
et cette fois-ci original
d'un côté comme il se concentre sur une
seule référence
ce paragraphe correspond davantage à
l'idéal de ma méthode
mais d'un autre côté je lui trouve quand
même deux défauts le premier défaut
c'est une grosse faute de conjugaison à
la deuxième phrase interpellé à
l'infinitif au lieu du participe passé
et tu vois que le correcteur qui est un
radar l'a bien évidemment trouvé cette
faute
le second défaut c'est le choix de la
référence qui n'est pas judicieux juste
la fin du monde est un film qui date de
2016 donc très récent et qui est plutôt
mal notées en plus on termine seulement
le grand 1 et famille a déjà cité deux
films donc ça fait trop mais bon en
dernière instance son 3e paragraphe est
tout de même efficace comme les deux
premiers fans y enchaîne avec la
conclusion partielle de son grand teint
ainsi temps l'écrivain que l'orateur ou
l'auditeur peuvent faire parler un texte
pourquoi cherche-t-il à 2,9 y vos
paroles écrites ou orales
ce sont donc deux phrases courtes la
première pour rappeler l'idée générale
de la partie la seconde la question pour
faire la transition vers l'idée générale
du grande c'est très simple et très
efficace
je n'ai rien à redire alors que penser
en conclusion de cette première grande
partie sur la forme elle est de très
bonne facture
les trois choses dont tu peux tu inspiré
ce sont je te les donne toujours par
ordre d'importance décroissante
l'obsession de famille à rester dans le
sujet on le voit bien avec la répétition
systématique de l'expression faire
parler un texte
la deuxième chose c'est la clarté de
l'expression écrite et enfin la
troisième c'est la structuration des
paragraphes ceux de cette première
grande partie
fanny les a préparées elles mêmes sur le
modèle de ceux du manuel 50 par ailleurs
tout cuit puis elle les a adaptés à son
argumentation
alors malgré ses trois atouts ce grand 1
n'est pas un modèle
pour une raison particulière je te l'aï
déjà dit ça n'est pas une bonne idée
d'avoir plus d'une référence dans un
paragraphe
si ce n'est de manière exceptionnelle
par exemple lorsqu'un auteur répond un
autre
allez je passe maintenant à la deuxième
grande partie je te rappelle que si tu
as des questions tu peux me les poser
dans les commentaires
[Musique]
alors fanny comment ce grand de avec une
introduction partielle pour rappeler
l'idée générale de la partie voyons
maintenant que le fait même de faire
parler un texte est entrepris pour
différentes raisons
c'est une bonne chose mais ça aurait été
mieux de la séparer du premier
paragraphe proprement dit avec un alinéa
ce paragraphe est le premier de la
dissertation qui est tirée du manuel 50
paragraphe tout de suite il s'agissait
plus précisément du numéro 23 de
l'édition sur le thème de la parole je
ne vais pas te le lire entièrement je te
le montre juste quelques secondes à
l'écran comme ça tu pourra revenir
dessus en mettant la vidéo en pause si
tu le souhaites maintenant comment fans
il at elle utilisé
elle a tout d'abord rédigé elle-même la
première phrase l'argument conformément
à ma méthode des paragraphes
tout d'abord pour l'écrivain faire
parler son texte lui permet de mieux
transmettre son message
[Musique]
c'est donc une phrase très clair qui
reprend en plus l'expression de l'énoncé
ce qui permet à famille de montrer
qu'elle a l'obsession de traiter le
sujet et rien que le sujet
le paragraphe du manuel proprement dit
ne commence qu'à la troisième phrase il
est souvent reproché à la parole famille
utilise très librement
elles l'utilisent grosso modo que la
moitié du paragraphe
elle n'en reprend pas les phrases mot
pour mot elle s'inspire simplement de la
formulation et surtout elle les adapte
très intelligemment au sujet et à son
argument par exemple quand elle écrit
que verlaine fait parler ses poèmes
pour finir elle ajoute une conclusion
partielle qui rappelle l'argument 6e
paragraphe est peut-être un peu court
par rapport à ceux du grand teint il est
très bon sur le plan de la méthode non
seulement fanni a sélectionné un
paragraphe du manuel pertinent sur le
fond mais elle l'a surtout adapté
intelligemment au sujet et à son
argumentation
elle se lève vraiment approprié pour les
besoins de l'épreuve
ça montre que tu n'es pas obligé comme
le croient certains élèves de prépa hec
d'apprendre par coeur les paragraphes
des deux manuels puis de les recracher
je le dis souvent mais le titre du
manuel cinq ans paragraphe tout cuit et
puis l'image la couverture c'est une
provocation qui ne reflètent pas tous
les usages possibles des paragraphes
en réalité comme famille tu peux
utiliser les paras garde du manuel très
librement en appliquant rigoureusement
la méthode des paragraphes aller fin de
la digression je passe paragraphe
suivant
[Musique]
le deuxième paragraphe de ce grand de et
lui aussi issu du manuel 50 par ailleurs
tout comme depuis le début de la
dissertation fanny reproduit le format
des paragraphes du manuel
elle commence avec une phrase très clair
qui présente l'argument puis elle
développe l'argument avec une phrase qui
vise à préciser l'idée précédente
elle introduit ensuite un passage
seulement deux phrases du paragraphe
numéro 43 du manuel avec la référence à
viktor klemperer et après elle utilise
trois phrases plus loin et pour une
seule phrase le paragraphe numéro 24
avec la référence à danton fanni fait
donc encore comme dans le paragraphe
précédent
un usage très libre des paragraphes du
manuel
cette fois ci cependant je trouve
qu'elle prend un risque
le premier problème c'est encore une
fois le doublement de la référence dont
je t'ai déjà exposé les inconvénients
en l'occurrence en plus j'aurais
inverser l'ordre des deux références en
soulignant que la seconde illustre le
versant négatif de la première le risque
de manipulation afférents à la capacité
à faire parler un texte mais bon je ne
suis pas censé parler du fond le second
problème est que fanny verse carrément
dans le name dropping deux phrases
seulement consacré à la première
référence et une seule à la seconde
c'est vraiment trop peu c'est du name
dropping et c'est condamnable
à quoi bon mobiliser une référence si
c'est pour l'évoquer en une phrase non
tu dois la développer au moins en trois
quatre phrases pour montrer en quoi elle
était l'idée du paragraphe c'est-à-dire
l'argument présenté par la première
phrase
[Musique]
en conclusion je ne te recommande pas en
termes de méthodes de t'inspirer de ce
paragraphe du développement cela étant
dit il présente toujours les mêmes
qualités de clarté de cohérence et de
fluidité que les précédents or ces
qualités sont très valorisé au concours
mais bon c'est quand même le premier
paragraphe un peu en dessous voyons voir
ce qu'il en est du dernier du grand est
[Musique]
où là ce troisième paragraphe est
excessivement court quatre phrases et il
me paraît d'autant plus que les deux
premiers paragraphes du développement
était très long de surcroît je ne vois
pas de référence alors même que la
plupart des paragraphes précédents en
combiné deux c'est le comble quand même
mobilisé deux références par paragraphe
et finir avec un paragraphe riquiqui
sans aucune référence
l'expression est toujours très claire
les liens logiques sont bien présents
mais ce paragraphe constitue
véritablement jusqu'ici le point bas de
la dissertation là la qualité de
l'expression est impuissante à compenser
la faiblesse de ce passage avec intel
paragraphe vraiment raté fanni fait une
croix sur les 18 19 20 des notes qui
n'était pas exclue à la lecture de tout
ce qui précède
bon on voit ensuite la conclusion
partielle du grand 2 qui paraît même
longue
comparé au dernier paragraphe elle est
rédigée sur le même modèle que celle du
grand emprunt elle est simple et
efficace
tu l'as compris cette deuxième grande
partie est à l'évidence bien en dessous
de la première
les trois erreurs que tu ne dois pas
reproduire ce sont je te les donne
encore par ordre d'importance
décroissante un fer à paragraphe avorton
comme le troisième de ce grand 2 qui se
réduit à quelques phrases et qui est
dépourvu de référence de faire du name
dropping comme dans le deuxième
paragraphe est là c'est d'autant plus
flagrant que fanni a encore combiné de
référence et enfin troisième erreur à
éviter
je viens de le dire combinée de
référence dans un même paragraphe je
pourrais aussi souligné que les
paragraphes paraissent finalement cours
en comparaison des deux premiers
paragraphes du développement de la
dissertation en définitive ce grand de
n'est donc pas terrible pour autant on
retrouve tout
l'obsession de famille à rester dans le
sujet est aussi la clarté de son
expression écrite et encore une fois ce
sont des qualités précieuses
allez je passe à la troisième et
dernière grande partie je te rappelle
que si tu as des questions tu peux me
les poser dans la partie commentaires
[Musique]
comme au début de la deuxième grande
partie famille écrit l'introduction
partielle dans le premier paragraphe
ce n'est pas très grave mais je te l'aï
déjà dit c'est plus clair de laisser
parle finalement montrons que la
possibilité de faire parler un texte
admet des limites voire peut se révéler
dangereux pour l'homme ou pour la parole
même dans cette introduction partielle
l'emploi du verbe montrer révèle bien
une fois de plus que fanni a pris la
mesure de l'exercice car elles se
placent explicitement dans un processus
d'argumentation elle annonce aux
correcteurs qu'elle s'apprête à
démontrer la pertinence de l'idée
générale de son grand troyes fanni ne se
prend pas non plus la tête pour
introduire cette troisième grande partie
l'adverbe finalement là rien de génial
mais il signale très simplement et très
clairement qu'on arrive à la dernière
phase de l'argumentation
alors le premier paragraphe proprement
dit il a été préparé par fanny elle même
sur le modèle de ceux du manuel
puis elle a adapté au sujet il est d'une
bonne longueur et puis il possède les
mêmes qualités que les bons paragraphe
précédent première phrase relativement
courte
un seul verbe conjugué est limpide
premièrement en faisant parler un texte
l'auditeur ou le lecteur risque de
trahir l'interprétation première de
l'écrivain ou de l'orateur une structure
transparente en commençant avec
l'adverbe premièrement
une cohérence accrue grâce aux liens
logiques 5 occurrence de l'expression
faire part à lire un texte pour montrer
qu'on est dans le sujet l'expression est
toujours très claires et enfin la petite
conclusion partielle qui va bien après
ce paragraphe présente cependant deux
défauts non négligeable le premier c'est
que la référence est introduite juste
après l'argument ce qui est trop tôt je
te rappelle qu'il faut idéalement deux
trois phrases entre l'introduction de
l'argument est celle de la référence et
le second défaut c'est qu'une seconde
des références pour un oui ou pour un
non de nathalie sarraute une pièce de
théâtre qui compte plutôt comme une
référence noble donc cette seconde
référence est introduite vers la moitié
du paragraphe
ce qui donne un peu l'impression de deux
paragraphes en un jeu teulé déjà dit je
ne vais pas te harceler avec ça mais
plusieurs références dans un même
paragraphe c est une mauvaise idée
bon malgré ces deux défauts ça passe
quand même parce que le collage de
l'introduction partielle au paragraphe
donne l'impression que la référence est
plus éloigné ça c'est pour le premier
défaut et pour le second défaut aucun
titre n'est souligné pour la première
référence donc en lisant vite ou peut
avoir l'impression qu'il n'y en a qu'une
seule
ce premier paragraphe est donc tout
compte fait plutôt efficace grâce aux
qualités profondes toujours les mêmes du
travail de fait je passe au suivant
[Musique]
dans le deuxième paragraphe fanny
combine un court passage du manuel 50
paragraphe tout de suite
la référence à noam chomsky avec un
autre passage la référence à ralph kayes
qu'elle a préparée elle même le
paragraphe est globalement réussi un
argument efficacement exposées dans la
première phrase
ensuite la capacité qu'ont certains
orateurs à faire part à lire un texte à
galvaniser autrui lors de sa lecture
créé un danger d'assujettissement pour
l'auditoire
là il ya une petite faute d'orthographe
que le correcteur à oublier il y a deux
thés assujettissement le paragraphe est
également réussie parce que sa structure
calqué sur les paragraphes du manuel
et comme dans l'art est de la copie
facilite la lecture
d'ailleurs fanni ne se prend pas la tête
pour l'introduire en commençant par
ensuite il est aussi bourré de liens
logiques on trouve trois occurrence de
faire parler un texte pour montrer qu'on
est bien dans le sujet l'expression
écrite est toujours très claires et le
paragraphe se referme avec une
conclusion partielle
sur le plan de la méthode des
paragraphes fanny customise bien les
passages qu'elle a empruntée pour les
faire correspondre à son argument elle
le fait par exemple en ajoutant en
donnant vie à leurs discours qui renvoie
à l'expression de l'énoncé en dernière
instance cet avant dernier paragraphe me
déçoit quand même à deux égards comme
dans le précédent
la première référence à être introduite
beaucoup trop tôt la deuxième phrase
et puis on retrouve une fois de plus de
références mais encore une fois
fanny réussit tout de même à faire
passer la pilule grâce à son style
simple et clair qui produit une bonne
impression de cohérence allez je passe
au tout dernier paragraphe du
développement dans ce paragraphe
fanny utilise deux références du manuel
50 paragraphe tout cuit les paragraphes
numéro 53 et 22 plutôt court et
peut-être même trop parce qu'il ne fait
que quatre phrases quand même ce
paragraphe un peu les qualités et les
défauts des précédents fanny fidèle à la
méthode des paragraphes et son style est
toujours aussi bon elle expose
efficacement l'argument encore une fois
sans se prendre la tête pour
l'introduire avec l'adverbe finalement
finalement se pose la question de
l'étendue de cette capacité à faire
parler un texte dans le paragraphe
elle reprend 4 fois l'expression
dénoncée elle dynamise l'expression avec
des questions pourquoi pas même si je
trouve que c'est plutôt compliqué à
faire étant donné que c'est le tout
dernier paragraphe de la dissertation
juste avant la conclusion elle ne s'est
pas embêtés à écrire une conclusion
partielle et elle a raison
malgré ses qualités le paragraphe est un
peu faible à trois égards tout d'abord
fanni fait simplement allusion aux deux
références elle ne les développons pas
du tout c'est encore du name dropping
ensuite encore une fois presque comme
dans toute la copie
elle combine encore de références et
enfin par rapport au paragraphe
précédent
le fonds est plus léger mais bon je ne
suis pas censé parler du thème
en clair ce tout dernier paragraphe
n'est pas super et il témoigne même je
trouve d'une certaine précipitation
en conclusion cette troisième grande
partie aurait pu être meilleur sur
l'échelle de la qualité je trouve
qu'elle est entre la première et la
deuxième les trois erreurs de cette
grande partie que tu ne dois pas
reproduire ce sont je te les donne
toujours par ordre d'importance
décroissante 1 introduit à la référence
trop tôt essaie de faire au minimum à la
troisième ou quatrième phrase du
paragraphe 2 le name dropping ça j'ai
déjà parlé
troisième erreur j'en ai déjà parlé
aussi parce que fanni il a fait dans
toute sa copie s'est combinée de
référence dans un même paragraphe après
les trois points positifs sont les mêmes
que pour les grands un et de la
pertinence la carte du style et la
structure argumentatif avec cette
troisième grande partie fanni se
rattrape un peu par rapport à la
deuxième mais je reste
quand même sur ma faim parce que le
grand 1 laissait espérer une super copie
allez c'est l'heure de mettre une note
[Musique]
alors qu'elles sont en synthèse les
qualités et les défauts principaux de la
copie pour moi fagnières réussi trois
choses sa dissertation et pertinente
c'est à dire qu'elles répondent très
précisément au sujet son style est très
claire et enfin son argumentation est
structuré très efficacement
c'est à dire qu'en lisant la copie on
comprend toujours pourquoi telle idée
est exposé à tel moment et on comprend
bien sa relation avec l'idée précédente
bien sûr es tu l'a bien vu mon
commentaire fanny a aussi raté des
choses
les trois défauts principaux de sa copie
ce sont je te lis donne comme d'habitude
par ordre d'importance décroissante la
problématisation est raté dans
l'introduction ou ne comprends pas
comment elle y arrive et puis ça n'était
pas ça le problème général posé par le
sujet deuxième défaut principal est bien
comme la problématisation et raté le
plan même s'il est clair n'est pas
terrible je ne sais pas si tu te
souviens mais le test de pertinence
n'étais pas confiant enfin troisième des
fonds les deuxième et troisième grande
partie les stades ya surtout la 12e avec
son 3e paragraphe avorte
bon maintenant qu'on connaît les trois
qualités et défauts principaux de la
dissertation de famille je peux vous
mettre à la place du correcteur
quelle note c'est copie mérite tête je
te l'aï déjà dit on ne peut pas lui
mettre entre 18 et 20 surtout à cause du
grand 2 puis aussi de la
problématisation après ces trois
qualités principales la pertinence la
clarté de l'expression et la
structuration de l'argumentation
ces trois qualités sont si précieuses
que c'est impossible de noter la copie
en dessous du seuil d'admissibilité qui
est à 14 h au sol
en conclusion la fourchette de notation
qui serait juste ça serait entre 14 et
c'est à dire que si fanni avait eu 14 15
ou 16
elle ne pourrait pas ce plan maintenant
la question c'est pourquoi 17
déjà moi je trouve que 14 ou 15 ça
serait un peu injuste dans la copie de
famille sort du lot par la pertinence et
la clarté général du propos et puis
comme dans les très bonnes copies il y a
très peu de fautes d'orthographe
je n'en ai trouvé que deux ou trois sur
dix pages et ça ça invite vraiment
attirer la note vers le haut donc en
dernière instance la copie de fanny me
semble méritée 16 ou 17
je tombe d'accord avec le correcteur
maintenant que dois-tu retenir de ce
commentaire je pense qu'il y à trois
dimensions fondamentales du travail de
fanny dont tu as intérêt à t'inspire là
je vais te les données par ordre
d'importance croissante donc prévient
attention à la troisième dimension la
première dimension fondamentale c'est
que fanny est très pragmatique elle sait
quel est l'enjeu d'une épreuve de
dissertation elle se contente de traiter
le sujet et unique - le sujet avec une
méthodologie éprouvée deuxième dimension
fondamentale de la réussite de fanny
elle n'écrit pas comme proust mais son
style est très clair comme celui des
paragraphes et ce style est très
agréable à lire pour le correcteur parce
qu'il n'a jamais à s'arrêter pendant sa
lecture pour s'interroger sur le
véritable sens d'une phrase cette
dimension peut expliquer à elle seule le
soir au terme de notes de 12 à 17
bah oui tu écris pour le correcteur donc
si tu rend sa lecture moins pénible ça
se traduira très favorablement dans ta
note je te le répète la clarté du style
est survalorisé au goncourt et pas qu'au
concours d'ailleurs mais aussi dans le
monde professionnel et de manière
générale dans la société parce qu'une
expression claire améliore la
transmission de l'information la clarté
de l'expression a donc une valeur
sociale importante
bon je ne vais pas dire et c'est sur ce
point je passe à la dimension la plus
importante du travail de fanny la
simplicité c'est cette dimension
fondamentale qui à mes yeux fait de la
copie de fanny un véritable modèle pour
toi
contrairement à la majorité des élèves
de prépa hec fanni ne s'est pas encombré
l'esprit avec mille et un détails
elle s'en est tenue aux choses simples
elle ne s'est pas pris la tête elle n'a
pas perdu de temps à essayer de faire
des transitions littéraire elle a juste
suivi un modèle élémentaire à la
paraffine et l'introduction de ces
arguments et de ses grandes parties elle
a quasiment toujours repris la même
trilogie
premièrement ensuite enfin c'est sûr que
c'est très simple mais au moins on
comprend très bien
et enfin surtout fanny ne s'est pas pris
la tête pour rédiger le développement
elle a simplement appliqué
rigoureusement ma méthode des
paragraphes elle a librement et
intelligemment utilisé les paragraphes
du manuel et ce qu'elle avait préparée
si tu veux toi aussi appliquer ma
méthode des paragraphes pour réussir à
produire au concours sans se prendre la
tête
une des certes ation de culture générale
qui séduisent le correcteur par sa
clarté
j'ai écrit une formation en ligne dans
laquelle je t'apprends comment faire
dans les moindres détails
tu peux en savoir plus soit en cliquant
sur le lien qui apparaît en haut à
droite de la vidéo soit sur celui qui
est dans la description dans cette
formation je t'expliquerai en détail
étape par étape comment élaborer la
stratégie avec ma méthode des
paragraphes et planifié intelligemment
ton travail
comment préparer ton stock de
paragraphes comment créer tes propres
paragraphe comme l'a fait fanny comment
apprendre efficacement des paragraphes
et enfin la phase cruciale pour laquelle
je vais encore plus dans le détail je
vais t'apprendre à utiliser tes
paragraphe en dissertation
voilà le programme de la formation si ça
t'intéresse tu peux en savoir plus
souhaite en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit sur celui qui est dans la
description
alors tu peux aussi très bien ton sortir
avec ma méthode des paragraphes
sans cette formation uniquement avec les
deux manuels mais si tu veux tirer le
maximum de la méthode des paragraphes ça
sera beaucoup plus facile et plus rapide
parce que ça prendra beaucoup plus de
temps si tu veux appliquer la méthode
par toi même
donc si tu veux tirer le maximum de la
méthode et économiser du temps du temps
que tu utiliseras pour devenir meilleur
en maths
au pot ou en économie pour ça la
formation à la méthode des paragraphes
est la meilleure solution
je te laisse donc allé voir la page de
présentation si ça t'intéresse et je
vais conclure cette vidéo ce que je veux
te dire pour terminer c'est que si fanni
a réussi alors qu'elle était seulement
partie pour éviter le pire en philo
c'est parce qu'elle a choisi les
solutions les plus simples
c'est parce qu'elle s'est libéré de tous
les détails qu'elle a assuré l'essentiel
en dissertation mener une réflexion
pertinente et s'exprimer clairement
voilà j'en ai terminé si tu as des
questions ça se passe dans les
commentaires et je te souhaite bon
courage pour le travail prak aristote ou
irrite bien une petite récompense finale
tu veux partir avec mon bâton vas-y
vas-y il s'enfuit avec allez bon courage
pour le travail
[Musique]
oh
hop
[Musique]